on a video link to the courtroom this is
maurice hall
he was in the car with george floyd on
the day he died
10 months ago
but the jury may never hear what he has
to say about that day
maurice hall plans to invoke his fifth
amendment right
to refuse to answer questions and avoid
incriminating himself
the judge will decide if it's worth
calling him as a witness at all
you swear or affirmatively perjury the
testimony about today will be the truth
and nothing but the truth
yes the jury has continued to hear from
former colleagues of the officer
accused of mr floyd's murder johnny
mercel trained derek chauvin
in use of force restraint he told the
jury had to be proportional
to resistance what about a knee on a
suspect's neck
sir is this an mpd trained
neck restraint no sir
has it ever been not to my neck no sir
[Music]
is this a mpd authorized restraint
technique
uh knee on the neck would be something
that does happen in use of course that
isn't
unauthorized and under what
circumstances would that be authorized
how long can you do that i don't know if
there's a time frame it would depend on
the circumstance of the time
which would include what the type of
resistance you're getting from the
subject that you're putting
me on right and so if there was uh say
for example
the subject was under control and
handcuffed
would this be authorized i would say no
eric chauvin's defense showed this image
from a training manual
illustrating the use of a knee while
handcuffing a suspect
very different the officer said
ultimately if that person were to be
handcuffed
and circumstances dictated the officer
would be permitted to continue to hold
his
knee in that same position agreed uh i
would say
uh yes uh however we've cautioned
officers that
be mindful of the neck area and to look
for the shoulder replacement
outside of court the family of george
floyd stood in a moment of prayer
this trial has been difficult to watch
they know
it is the process of justice they've
demanded greg milam sky news minneapolis